should Hollywood director James Gunn
have been fired for making pedophile
jokes
ten years ago samuel l.jackson William
Shakespeare and the Lord your God weigh
in then Alan Dershowitz joins to discuss
whether Democrats will or even can
impeach President Trump
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh there's a lot to get to today we have
got a further evidence that Donald Trump
is the Vengeance of the Lord your God
but we will explain ow first we got to
make a little money honey we got a we
got to talk about look I want to thank
my sponsors it keeps and I want to just
send a direct message to all of you I am
NOT an Adonis of a man okay I'm
perfectly willing to admit that I'm not
a herculean type of figure but I've
always had one advantage when it comes
to the ladies I'm gonna tell many tales
out of school here I've got a nice
fluffy head of hair you should keep your
hair it's very easy to keep your hair
and a lot of men will start to lose
their hair between the ages of 25 and 30
it starts that early people don't think
about that you think like when you're 50
you lose your ear
no it's so it's very early and it's very
easy to keep the hair you have but you
have to get started use keeps this is
clinically proven to work you know the
solution there there are two clinically
proven medications that let you keep
your hair there now inexpensive and
they're easy to get you don't need to
lose your hair if you don't want to it's
it's five minutes right now and it costs
just a dollar a day or less and you'll
never have to worry about hair loss
again that and think about how much
money you spend on lattes less than a
dollar a day to keep your hair and have
women looking at you and kind of winking
at you down the street get started today
it takes five minutes to sign up it's
very easy just answer a few questions
snap some photos a licensed doctor will
review that information recommend the
right treatment for you all without you
ever leaving your couch which is the
only way I do anything uh they're
generic versions of the only two FDA
approved hair loss products out there
you might have tried them before you've
never gotten them this easy for this
price ten to fifteen bucks a month and
you get your first month free don't say
I never did nothing for you one hell of
a deal forgetting to keep your hair stop
hair loss today it's easy with keeps
receive your first month of treatment
for free don't say I never did nothing
for you get poofy hair just like mine or
keep the ferbiere you've got goto keeps
calm / go FFA COV fe fe that is ke e PS
gum / cough fa c OV e f EF e that is a
free month of treatment keeps calm /
cough fa keeps hair today hair tomorrow
okay back to pedophiles back to the
pedophiles in hollywood so you saw james
gunn who's the director for guardians of
the galaxy who's better at inherit the
whole Marvel Universe you know as a
up and comer in Hollywood major player
he just got killed got fired from Disney
because he made pedophile jokes ten
years ago and some people are saying
maybe it's more than jokes Hollywood has
a pedophile problem is he part of that
others are saying this is just a
witch-hunt
you know he says negative things about
Trump and he's an anti Trump ER and his
he's basically getting what he deserves
there-there was just a character
assassination for reaction though
because now sever is hitting everybody
Trevor Noah's getting hit for racial
tweets that he sent out years and years
ago there were all these up Michael Ian
Black said some weird pedophile tweet
Sarah Silverman made some weird
pedophile tweets Patton Oswalt made some
weird pedophile tweets all of this a for
reaction we cut now to every single
person in Hollywood we got it definitely
write a song about how we do not diddle
kids
it's no good diddling kids
there is no quicker way for people to
think that you're diddling kids than by
writing a song about it you gotta race
always it says oh I wouldn't do it with
anybody younger than my daughter no
little kids gotta be big I don't know if
that's gonna work I don't know if that's
gonna convince anybody so this is the
question should James Gunn have been
fired for this should these people who
made jokes ten years ago
should they be liable for those things
now you know it couldn't have happened
to a better guy that's how that's what
I'll first say about it it couldn't have
happened to a nicer guy James Gunn is
the first one on the line to say kill
people make the not killed not literally
figuratively kill their careers make
them lose their jobs cancel their shows
because I disagree with them politically
James Gunn is the first guy to do that
he's the first in line he said ears ax
ear a couple tweets from him not the
pedophile tweets but the anti free
speech once he says quote I wish some of
these so called defenders of Liberty
would start to understand what freedom
of speech is and isn't Rosanna is
allowed to say whatever she wants
doesn't mean ABC needs to continue
funding her TV show if her words are
considered abhorrent okay alright fess a
fair argument James but you know be
careful when you throw stones let's see
what happens to you he also said about
Laura Ingraham he said I hope hulu stops
advertising on the laura
Ingram show so I can watch it online
bullying and shaming of teenagers should
not be supported by Hulu let them know
and he said about the same thing about
about Laura Ingraham I'm really looking
forward to season two of Handmaid's Tale
so I hope hulu stops advertising on the
aunt Lydia show I mean on the Laura
Ingraham show so I can watch it online
bullying and shaming of teenagers should
not be supported by Hulu let them know
so James James Gunn this guy's saying
fire laura ingraham fire Roseanne they
should all lose their shows for in
Roseanne's case a joke they made and in
Laura Ingraham skates just cuz he
disagrees with her politics and now it
comes back to him be careful about this
this made me realize across a whole
broad array of spectrum that not just
Hollywood but in foreign affairs in
politics to the news media Donald Trump
is the Vengeance of the Lord Donald
Trump is the vengeance of the Lord it
made me think of samuel l.jackson in
Pulp Fiction here's here's samuel
l.jackson explaining donald trump
Ezekiel 25:17 the path of the righteous
man is beset on all sides by the
inequities of the selfish and the
tyranny of evil men blessed is he who in
the name of charity and goodwill
Shepherds the weak through the valley of
darkness for he is truly his brother's
keeper and the finder of lost to and I
will strike down upon thee with great
vengeance and furious anger those who
attempt to poison and destroy my
brothers and you will know my name is
the Lord when I lay my vengeance upon
thee
that's it he's the Vengeance of the Lord
you know it's funny because samuel
l.jackson on that movie says I'm quoting
Ezekiel 25:17 I think but he's actually
misquoting it he's got a lot of other
stuff in there that isn't in Ezekiel
25:17 this is the direct quote and I
will execute great vengeance upon them
with furious rebukes and they shall know
that I am the Lord when I shall lay my
vengeance upon them this is I'm not
saying Donald Trump is is laying his
vengeance I'm not saying he's I'm saying
he is the vengeance Donald Trump is the
vengeance he is the double-standard
destroyer he wrecks the double standards
in all of these people because you know
it when I saw the James gun thing my
first reaction is this is an ugly
culture this is a really ugly culture
where we're just gonna punish intended
gunning to destroy people for things
they said 10 years ago what jokes did I
make 10 years ago I don't know do I make
some off-color jokes yeah sure for sure
I don't know which ones but on certainly
I did did you yes you did - so did every
single person so should people lose
their careers because of jokes even bad
jokes even crass jokes even unfunny
jokes that they made 10 years ago no I
don't think so but if you're gonna if
you're gonna dish it you better be able
to take it and James Gunn that's those
are the rules he wants to play by we
didn't make those rules we didn't make
the rules that you lose your job because
you make a bad joke or because you made
a bad joke ten years ago that was the
left that did that that was James Gunn
begging for it over and over and over
and now he is being swept up in what you
deal out you're gonna have to receive
back in return and President Trump is
the one to give it to you he is the
evidence of that do we like the politics
of personal destruction know that phrase
by the way coined because of the things
that Hillary Clinton was saying about
her husband's accusers she says their
trailer-trash their this their that no I
don't like that at all but if they're
gonna dish it out we're not gonna
unilaterally disarm no way that would be
crazy we're not gonna lie down and let
them destroy the culture destroy our
politics destroy our media know if
they're gonna claim a scalp we're gonna
claim a scalp James Gunn it was it's
good that he lost his job
it's a good thing in this context
because they're dishing it out but it
would be much better if we lived in a
culture where you could just tell jokes
you didn't have to deal with this if we
lived in a culture where the president
didn't have to go out and have personal
invective against people or say these
things or be you know loud mouthed or be
aroused the public passion I don't think
the president should be arousing the
public passions but if the left is going
to do it we have to do it too if if
Barack Obama is gonna go out there rub
our nose in every cultural victory that
he has if he's gonna rewrite the
Constitution and then paint the White
House in rainbow colors then absolutely
Donald Trump should go out there and rub
their nose in it too absolutely that is
the Vengeance that they have asked for
that is their just desert and I don't I
I don't want to live in a world of just
deserts but if they're gonna have it we
have to answer that and once they decide
to back down a little bit on the left
then we can back down to you see this
even in in Iran you know the the it's
just Donald Trump is just the double
standard smasher in Iran the the
President of Iran
rou-ha-nee he said you know he was very
upset that President Trump is ripping up
that awful nuclear deal that Obama
negotiated and so he said you know peace
with Iran is a wonderful terrific peace
and war with Iran is war unlike anything
you've ever seen and they're rattling
Iran always rattles right they say death
to America they're always saber rattling
saying awful things about America and
American presidents lie down and take it
not president Trump President Trump
tweeted in all caps to Iranian president
rouhani never ever threatened the United
States again or you will suffer
consequences the likes of which very few
throughout history have ever suffered
before we are no longer a country that
will stand for your demented words of
violence and death be cautious now do I
want the president to have to say these
things do I want the president to have
to scream like this digitally scream
which means all capitals no I don't want
that but I but I'm not I'm not gonna
live in a world where the United States
just takes it where these tin-pot
dictator Zin Iran or wherever these
mullahs start saying crazy things to us
and start threatening the United States
and we say okay well that's fine that's
no no way buddy you guys calm down and
we'll calm down too but we can't have it
we can't have it that way of some people
now the experts are saying
well you know rouhani he's really just
he's just saying that to get the
hardliners off his back he's really oh
he's just look he's he's not really
making a threat he's really just trying
to get the pressure off of him from the
hardliners yeah okay well maybe he
should have tried to get the pressure
off a different way than huh because
that is not acceptable that is not
acceptable behavior in the international
community we're not going to take it
anymore very very pleased to see that
how about how about quarter-page so in
this you've seen this quarter-page
application the Phi's application has
been revealed in some way it's still
heavily redacted but Judicial Watch got
this application to find out if Barack
Obama's administrative agencies were
spying on the Trump campaign the answer
is yes they had made statements in
public they said no no we weren't we
didn't use the Democrat funded steel
dossier to spy on quarter-page it what
now we didn't use that really at all
that was very minor we know from this
application that's not true it was based
on the steel dossier the steel dossier
was ordered and funded by Democrats it
was poisoned fruit from the very
beginning and they lied they lied these
people that we said we can't criticize
the FBI you can't criticize the CIA you
can't criticize James Comey or Bob
Muller or John Brennan you're not
allowed to criticize them no we need to
we need to build up our intelligence
agencies our administrative agencies
it's terrible to criticize them sure but
they need to act in the right ways and
if they're gonna be corrupted if they
are gonna act as partisan hacks that are
spying on a presidential campaign then
we're gonna have to criticize tomorrow
we're gonna have to attack them it would
be better to live in a world where we
didn't have to do that but we're not
going to lie down we're not going to
allow this double standard
not anymore Tunnel Trump is not going to
allow that to happen you know the FBI
said that said on four separate
occasions that the steel dossier was not
the source for that Isikoff article one
of the articles that was also used to
spy on quarter-page we now know that
wasn't true how long is the smaller
investigation going on for what is the
purpose of this what is the scope why
are why is Bob Muller the most important
man in Washington we can't tolerate
these double standards any more no way
that you know that actually that whole
bit from Ezekiel 25 is is important the
whole
the thing that see me while Jackson
misquoted it's important it tells you
about our moment Ezekiel 25 reads this
is what the sovereign Lord says because
the Philistines acted in vengeance and
took revenge with malice in their hearts
and with ancient hostility sought to
destroy Judah therefore this is what the
sovereign Lord says I am about to
stretch out my hand against the
Philistines and I will wipe out the
Kerith i'ts and destroy those remaining
along the coast I will carry out great
vengeance on them and punish them in my
wrath then they will know that I am the
Lord when I take vengeance on them the
the reason he is taking vengeance on
them the reason there is a vengeance of
the Lord is because the Philistines
acted in vengeance and took revenge if
they're gonna do it they're gonna get
back what they have but there is another
there is another option it would be much
better to live in a world where we
didn't have to do that where you didn't
have your career ruined for saying I
choked ten years ago where you didn't
have to have the president screaming you
know apparently like a crazy person but
maybe that crazy person is the last same
guy in the world you it would be much
better to live in a world of mercy and
grace it reminds me of this line from
The Merchant of Venice that the Porsche
says to [ __ ] and I'm probably now the
what was that at the Southern Poverty
Law Center is now they're gonna say
here's evidence that Knowles is a racist
he quotes The Merchant of Venice so get
ready for that one but it's a great line
I remember this from acting school
Portia - [ __ ] says though justice be
thy plea consider this that in the
course of justice none of us should see
salvation we do pray for mercy and that
same prayer doth teach us all to render
the deeds of mercy I've spoke thus much
to mitigate the justice of thy plea
which if thou follow this strict Court
of Venice must needs give sentence
against the merchant there in the course
of justice none of us should see
salvation so if if the left is gonna
keep this up and say we're gettin him
we're gonna get anywhere to get this
show canceled we're gonna get this guy
fired then we're gonna do it - and well
and see what kind of see what kind of
society that is see if you like that see
if you like a taste of your own medicine
it's an ugly Society it's an ugly
divisive society and I hope that the
left gets the message here probably they
won't all right we've got a speaking of
this this exact question we've got to
bring on Alan Dershowitz to see if the
left is going to learn their lesson or
if they're going to go ahead and try to
impeach Trump for
absolutely no reason if they're gonna
try to create some totally bogus just
political story anti legal case to
impeach Trump Alan Dershowitz you all
know him he is the world renowned
scholar of con law and criminal law he
is the author of the case against
impeaching Trump Alan Dershowitz
professor Dershowitz at age 28 became
the youngest law professor in the
history of Harvard University he also
famously got oj off but now he's getting
more flex for defending president Trump
defending the double murder that's fine
defending President Trump absolutely
unacceptable we talked to professor
Dershowitz there's no greater expert in
the country on this question than him
and we will analyze will the Democrats
learn their lessons the vengeance of the
Lord or are they gonna try to impeach
President Trump here is professor
Dershowitz professor Dershowitz thank
you so much for being here thank you
so you've you've done the unthinkable
thing in our current political climate
which is you were defending president
Trump against the ubiquitous calls on
the political left for impeachment I
noticed there are many Democrats who are
you know they'll be in their Twitter bio
it will say hashtag impeach Trump a
Maxine Waters is saying that impeachment
is whatever Congress says it is that
there's no law about that other people
have said that in the past in your book
you say totally otherwise what what is
the case against impeachment for those
who have not yet read the book well of
course it's really a relatively simple
argument that is the framers of our
Constitution considered making the
criteria of their impeachment
maladministration in office or other
european british criteria for removing a
president they rejected it and they said
in order to remove a president
particularly you need to have evidence
of treason bribery or other high crimes
and misdemeanors those are very specific
you'll require crimes you need to have a
trial in the Senate there has to be a
conviction and a conviction must be
based on a two-thirds vote of the Senate
if any of those criteria fail you cannot
remove a president and just like you
can't change the two-thirds requirement
you also can't change the requirement of
a conviction for trees
bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors you can't just make it up
even if you don't like the president I
made the same argument by the way when
Bill Clinton was being impeached I've
made the same argument when Richard
Nixon was being impeached I'll make the
same argument when Bernie Sanders gets
elected president and he gets impeached
in fact you know I'm so determined to
make that point that I have the
publisher come up with a mock cover from
my book and it's called the case against
impeaching Hillary Clinton because
that's the book I would have written and
Hillary Clinton it'll like the president
would have been exactly the same book
just with the title and inside I would
have been talking about how you can't
prosecutor for obstruction of justice
for the emails and that there was no
crime exactly the same argument but
they'd be building statues to me on
Martha's Vineyard and other liberal
enclaves if I were making this case for
Hillary Clinton but making the identical
case word-for-word case for a president
I didn't vote for I opposed I campaigned
against has caused me to literally lose
friends and and people just won't engage
they won't even get involved in the
conversation they do not want to hear
the other argument they remind me of
college kids and college professors who
want safe spaces trigger warnings please
don't tell me anything I don't want to
hear I don't want you to upset that's
the level of discourse we've gotten to
in America today it is really quite sad
when you see these members of Congress
or even senators saying impeach impeach
they think it's just a political matter
and they they say it pretty explicitly
you know Maxine Waters said that
impeachment is whatever I say it is and
I think people are losing sight that
there is a there is a crime component
here they can't just do it you point out
in the book that and the Constitution
points this out to that when the the
president is being tried the Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court has a role
he's presiding over that I mean what
does that say about the the role of
crime the role of the judiciary here and
reigning in Congress from just doing
whatever it wants and throwing out a
president that it doesn't like well
Hamilton explained that in the
Federalist Papers
said there was some who wanted to have
the Supreme Court presiding over the
trial of a president and the compromise
he used that term compromised was to
have the Chief Justice preside now the
Chief Justice doesn't preside just
because he looks pretty in robes Oh what
did lend dignity to the proceeding he
presides because he is the chief
judicial officer in the United States
and he has a role to play and if I were
the president's lawyer and he will
impeach Diane OTT but if I were or the
first motion I would make if you were
impeached for something that wasn't a
constitutionally specified crime I might
make a motion to the Chief Justice to
dismiss the impeachment the same way
you'd make a motion to dismiss an
indictment in front of a judge before
they can be a trial so this is a legal
proceeding there is a political element
even if the president commits
impeachable offenses Congress doesn't
have to remove him if political
considerations lead to less than
two-thirds of the vote to remove him he
stays in office but he has to be
impeached only and removed only on the
basis of these specified crimes so it's
a necessary but not sufficient condition
politics only comes into play once
there's evidence enough evidence to
convince two-thirds of a Senate that he
has committed an impeachable crime right
and and it's interesting because you're
bringing out all of the legal aspect the
constitutional and the legal aspects and
all people are talking about is the
political aspect of this so I think
you've pointed it out before you're
getting much more flak for defending the
president against impeachment than
you've got for defending OJ Simpson in
his murder trial people are really
really fired up about this and you bring
up some interesting questions in this
book which is that for instance a
removal from office is not enforced is
not self-enforcing someone has to remove
him so what happens you know what
happens if the president says I don't
want to be removed from office and say
yeah it's so interesting each man has
been on our books for 225 years
I know of no academic who has ever
raised this question before none let's
assume the Senate were to remove order
him removed by a two-thirds vote for
four maladministration in office there
are three branches
each can interpret the Constitution as
they believe is justified if the Senate
interprets the Constitution is saying we
can remove a president for a non-prime
and the president says no that's not my
interpretation by legal counsel my
advisers all tell me you need a crime
the president says this is an
unconstitutional act of removal I'm not
going anywhere at that point what is the
Congress going to do pull out the
marshals right pull out the army No
bring it to the United States Supreme
Court when we have a conflict between
constitutional interpretation by the
President and by the Congress as we did
in Marlborough versus Madison the case
goes to the United States Supreme Court
two justices have already a pine that
they very well might have jurisdiction
to consider a case that Congress acts
beyond its authority but again I don't
know of a single academic who has said
that the court has a role to play so I'm
out there all alone
but I'm very comfortable out there
because I think I'm right if you
disagree with me read the book write
your own book write an article write a
book review argue with me defeat me in
the court of public opinion but don't
refuse to engage with me even if I'm
wrong and it's possible I'm wrong I've
laid out an important constitutional
argument that nobody laid out before and
that argument has to be taken into
account especially if we try to remove a
duly elected president of the United
States of course because you might win
in the short term but you'll certainly
that creates awful precedent in in the
long run and it's it's so funny that
people on the left are disparaging you
for this as though you've you know
shifted sides all of a sudden Alan
Dershowitz is as some conservative
Republican hack or something you're the
one who has remained consistent here it
is partisans I suppose on both sides who
keep shifting their arguments but I
wonder in this climate especially you
see it in particular on campuses but you
see it in political discourse too people
seem to have very little respect for
reason for civil arguments for engaging
with the other side a very little
interest in referencing the law or the
Constitution does
that spell a sort of demise or doom for
our constitutional Republican for our
political culture or is this just more
of the same partisan arguments that we
see again and again over the years look
we've had this for decades in my own
lifetime we saw a liberal president
United States detain 110,000
japanese-americans in detention camps
and who supported that all the liberal
justices to the Supreme Court Douglas
and black and and others centers were
more conservative we saw it during the
McCarthy carrillo this time it's
different
communism is such a great threat we have
to really deny civil liberties or the
Vietnam War let's draft political
dissenters to stop them from dissenting
or after 9/11 in every generation I've
seen efforts to limit civil liberties
and what's different about this one is
with Trump you have to pick sides
nobody's know neither must hate him and
think he is the worst president in the
history of the country or you must love
him and think he's the best and there's
almost no room for nuance and even if
you hate him to think he's the worst you
have to defend his civil liberties
consists of liberties are are civil and
even deny a president
constitutional rights you can deny
anybody constitutional rights and all
the arguments I'm making are civil
libertarian and liberal arguments and
again if Hillary Clinton were the one
who was being impeached for prosecuting
all the liberals would be making the
same exact arguments but because I make
them at a time when Trump is the
president
I'm regarded as a pariah of the left and
also what's even more disturbing is I'm
a hero with the right I don't want to
hear from supporter I'm not somebody who
is making this argument only because
it's Trump I'm making this argument
because I support the Constitution of
the United States so both sides
misunderstand me look it's clear when I
you know I'm a fervent Boston Red Sox
fan and some of my best friends are New
York Yankee fans and you know you can't
there's no argument either the Red Sox
are the greatest team in baseball they
are or the Yankees are the greatest team
they were but you can't have a kind of
argue
yeah excited you have teams that's
what's happening it's okay in sports
it's not okay in governance you know as
you were pointing out that you've now
become an unwitting and unlikely hero to
the political right I was trying to
figure out in my studio where I was
going to put up the alan dershowitz a
poster but then you made that comment
about the Red Sox and the Yankees and
I've got to scrap the plans altogether
unfortunately now there is one aspect
where nuance has been coming in on the
pro-impeachment side here though which
is that people who were calling for the
impeachment of Trump are saying that he
colluded with Russia and this is somehow
sufficient to impeach him does collusion
rise to the level of high crimes and
misdemeanors
it doesn't even rise to the level of
look crimes is not a crime collusion is
not a crime except that business people
collude together to violate the
antitrust laws in my book the case
against impeaching Trump I give the most
extreme hypothetical during the campaign
candidate Trump pulls up president and
says hey glad do I have a deal for you I
want to be elected president I know you
have some dirt on Hillary Clinton you've
already gathered if you send me the dirt
on Hillary Clinton that helped me get
elected president it's much more likely
that we'll get rid of these sanctions
does I don't like these sanctions uh
that's what politicians do all the time
they say to people give me money give me
support you know I'm on your side
I'll help be pro-choice I'll help be
pro-gun control vote for me because I'm
gonna help your agenda that's not a
crime now people say it's different
business the foreign government but what
the foreign government was doing here is
giving under my hypothetical information
information is different from money
because it's protected by the First
Amendment for the same reason the New
York Times Washington Post was able to
publish the Pentagon Papers Snowden
Manning all of those stolen materials is
once it's stolen the First Amendment
protects its publication or it's used by
a candidate now if candidate Trump said
to the Republican and to the Boonton
please hack the Democratic National
Committee that would be a crime because
then he is urging them to do a crime
if he says if you've already hacked them
and you have the information give it me
that's no more crime than what the
Washington Post and The New York Times
did that's a great point and before I
let you go I've already taken up a lot
of your time I do want to ask about the
procedural aspects of all of this we've
got the Muller investigation I think at
this point it's been going on since 1857
or so it looks like it'll be going on
forever and yet you hear from partisans
on both sides that if one is to
criticize the Muller team or mr. Muller
himself that is at an outrage it's an
attack on the American administrative
agencies or whatever the investigative
services the intelligence services is it
kosher it to put it bluntly is it kosher
to criticize or question Muller well
it's so interesting because I grew up is
a liberal all my life on the liberal
what a liberals do they question law
enforcement right what did liberals do
when the Bay of Pigs happen we
questioned intelligence what happened in
the run-up to the iran-iraq war we
questioned the WMD intelligence we
always questioned intelligence we're
always critical of the FBI I spent most
of my career as a young man criticizing
J Edgar Hoover and the FBI that's what
liberals did conservatives always came
to the defense and said we believe in
law and order and liberals said we
believe in civil liberties so the idea
that liberals are now the one saying oh
my god you ever questioned i ACEA hey I
mean talk about hypocrisy with a capital
H my god that's what liberals and civil
libertarians have always been doing but
now that Muller is the guy who might be
able to get Trump he is no longer an
appropriate subject well it is quite
ironic it hadn't occurred to me until
you you put it that way that four years
at this point even in recent memory the
left has pilloried local law enforcement
they've said we need to abolish ice
that's one of the lines in this campaign
that we need to demilitarize the police
take away power from the police and then
in the same breath they're saying if you
criticize law enforcement at the federal
level or in with regard to President
Trump you're some sort of anti-american
traitor that that is a
real irony it's obvious it's civil
liberties for me but not for thee
free speech for me but not for thee and
that's what's called hypocrisy uh if
you're gonna be a civil libertarian and
a supporter of free speech you have to
be a supporter of those concepts no
matter who the beneficiary is and who
the loser is when I was a kid in college
I defended the right of Communists to
speak at Brooklyn College I hated
communism I was brought up in a very
anti-communist household but I supported
the right of Communists to speak and to
run for office
so I early on in my life and then I
supported the rights of Nazis the
marches in Skokie my mother didn't talk
to me she said who 31 the Nazis are the
Jews and I said mom on the site of civil
liberties and she said don't give me
that I'm Your Mother
you got to pick sides the Jews or the
Nazis well my mother wasn't
college-educated but the people who are
criticizing me today are many of them
lawyers they have to know that if you
believe in civil liberties you will
sometimes end up defending people you
don't like it was HL Mencken who said
first they go after the SOPs and they
established the precedent on them and
then they come after the rest of us
that's why I'm going to continue to
defend the rights of every American
whether David Duke or whether it's some
communist on the left or whether it's a
president Trump or President Clinton or
or Bernie Sanders or anybody else I
don't think you can draw lines depending
on whose side people are on I always ask
myself have I passed the shoe on the
other foot test if the shoe were on the
other foot if it were gore versus bush
rather than Bush versus Warren the
Supreme Court of come out the other way
I wrote a book saying no I wrote a book
called supreme injustice the Liberals
loved my book because I criticized the
Supreme Court but if I made the same
criticism today of law enforcement and
judicial I'd be a pillory so I'm gonna
stick to my guns I've been doing it I'm
almost 80 I've been doing it that's been
my life I'm not changing now I I think
that's a great point and the the book is
really really good I really enjoyed it
the case against impeaching Trump my
last question before I let you go you
know you've you obviously have an
expertise and pre-eminent expertise on
these matters as a matter of law and
constitution
as a matter of politics if you were a
gambling man do you think that the
partisans the pro-impeachment crowd will
impeach Trump if given the opportunity
or do you think that your sound
arguments and cooler heads will prevail
well I think there'll be many in the
Democratic Party who will want to
impeach Trump already some people are
running on that platform a real jerk who
is a professor at the University of
Minnesota named painter who's running on
an impeached Trump campaign there are
others who are running on an impeached
Trump campaign it will hurt the
Democrats if they do that just like it
hurt the Republicans when they impeach
Clinton it's easy to get an impeachment
if you control the house but very hard
to get a removal so my prediction here
is unless there's new evidence that
comes out material we're not aware of
I don't think President Trump will be
removed from office other than through
elections and might very well be removed
office in the 2020 election and that's
something that people who are opposed to
him should be focusing on not in each
'men excellent point and I really really
enjoy the book so I encourage everybody
to read it
the case against impeaching Trump by
Alan Dershowitz I think you've written
about 750,000 other books which are also
quite good but I really recommend
reading this it is just finally a cool
logical arguments that simply are not
really getting airtime as people are
blowing a bunch of partisan hot air
professor Dershowitz thank you so much
for being here thank you so much I
appreciate it
Alan Dershowitz he lays it out is the
last liberal standing in the world I
think the last honest liberal we've got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
thank you if you're already on Daily
wire you help keep the lights on you
keep khofifah in my cup if you're not go
to daily where right now it's 10 bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership you
get me you get the under claiming sure
you got the Ben Shapiro show you get to
ask questions in the mailbag you get to
ask questions which by the way is coming
up Thursday get your questions in get to
ask questions in the conversation I
think I'm coming up next so get ready
for that again none of that matters you
need the leftist here's tumblr you need
the this is the James Gunn edition
obviously we got a little common-sense
gun control here look
hello I don't I don't want to I'm not
trying to destroy James gun I just I'm
not trying to take away James Gunn's
career I just want some common-sense gun
control and to collect all those
delicious tears in my left chest years
tumblr but I have a favor to ask of you
I look I don't I I only ask for your
money and help for a stupid joke like
once a year at this point I think that's
my record so you might have seen the
shapiro store has opened up the long
awaited the shapiro store which been has
been promising since like the clinton
administration and we finally got it up
and it's got some shirts so there's a
shirt up with my face on it they've got
a couple presidential series and they've
got this one which says i like Mike on
it and they've got one for Ben too and
they've got one for Drew I I need you to
go buy this shirt and not because you
need to wear it probably if you wear it
in polite society
you'll just be pilloried beaten with an
Tifa batts you know it won't go well but
the reason you need to buy this shirt is
I think it would be very very funny if I
sell more shirts than Ben I really
really want that to happen I don't think
the grin will ever leave my face if I
manage to do that so I need I need you
to go buy this shirt to make Ben frown
and to give me some chuckles for like I
don't know like a month or two at least
I got good simplifier gum right now I
want to wrap up on this question of
Russia why Russia keeps coming up what
it really means what it has to do with
with the Vengeance of the Lord will have
all that more go to daily wire.com we'll
be right back
too much fun to him everything for
selling more shirts than been really
that would be the most fun of all but
watching the logic of these lefties play
out right on them it's like them you
know they're like they're aiming at
Donald Trump with a boomerang and they
say well I'm gonna get Trump now and
they throw it right but it doesn't quite
hit Trump does it no it just boom hits
him right in the head and it's great to
watch that logic turn out because for so
long it's been a double standard they
get to run roughshod over us and we're
not allowed to fight back we said no we
can't oh it would be oh no we would be
so uncouth that's not nice well one
simply doesn't do that where you should
drink your tea with your pinky out right
and then in comes Donald Trump a
vengeance of the Lord and we see a play
out on them this is all focused on
Russia right now right they're all as a
matter of politics they're aiming to get
Trump on Russia
you've got candidates campaigning for
for Congress for the Senate on an
impeached rump platform what crime did
he commit um what are what are the legal
grounds for impeachment arm right that's
just but they're gonna do it and the
question is why does President Trump let
this go on not just let this go on why
does he play into it I had a professor
friend of mine I won't say where he's a
professor it's not professor Dershowitz
and he messaged me and he said you know
Michael I I really think Trump might be
guilty here he sounds so guilty he
always is saying it's a witch hunt and
all the exclamation points why is he
what's sounding like a guilty guy why is
he letting this Russia thing keep going
on and on and on and you know I know
that everybody thinks that Donald Trump
is an idiot that's that's the line
conservatives seem to think that left
certainly thinks that he's not an idiot
he's a smart guy and is it did it ever
occur to you that maybe this Russia
narrative plays to president Trump's
advantage that it actually gives him an
advantage in electoral politics today we
would consider that we were saying why
didn't he fire jeff Sessions when Jeff
Sessions recused himself he's fired
everyone else in the cabinet why not
Jeff Sessions did it ever occur to
people that maybe this Russia story
helps Trump because why wouldn't it
you're just a little bit of evidence so
first of all to answer my
for friends question did isn't this
evidence that President Trump committed
a crime no it is first of all what crime
if this were evidence some smoking gun
you know President Trump was gonna be
taken down over this don't you think
he'd be at least accused of a crime what
crime has he been accused of as
president professor Dershowitz just said
collusion is not a crime it's just a
silly little euphemism that the left is
using to cudgel Donald Trump but that's
not a crime so you'd think he might be
accused of a crime if if he were guilty
of something they'd have something on
him this has been going on now for two
years don't you think they'd have
something on him at this point something
tangible they could wrap around and the
molar investigations been going on since
the grant administration at this point
they don't have anything on them also
don't you think if they had something on
him maybe his accusers wouldn't have so
much to cover up I mean James Comey lied
John Brennan has lied the the FBI
political players in the FBI the CIA
they've been revealed to have allied
during all of this they the the meeting
on the tarmac between president former
President Clinton and Loretta Lynch
James Comey saying that Hillary clearly
committed a crime but we're not going to
get her for it anyway we've drafted up
memos exonerating Hillary Clinton before
we even interviewed Hillary Clinton why
don't we have the DNC server that was
allegedly hacked why don't we oh isn't
it a little weird don't you think that
these guys might have a little less at
stake you know if President Trump if
they really had something on him if it
weren't just a political action but why
does he allow it to keep going and why
does President from keep it in the news
whenever this thing goes out of the news
president from sins another tweet he
says it's a witch-hunt explanation why
would me if it were really a danger to
his presidency wouldn't he be quiet
about it maybe it's not a danger to his
presidency maybe this is exactly the
right strategy for Republicans you know
according to Gallup fewer than half a
percent of Americans think that this
Russia collusion thing is an important
public issue not just less than 1% less
than half a percent of Americans think
that this is an important issue
Americans care about immigration they
care about the economy they care about
Foreign Affairs broadly in a wars and
things like that
nuclear weapons in North Korea they do
not care about Russia at all I mean
statistically is zero percent of
Americans care about this Democrats have
put all their eggs in this basket and
President Trump is forcing them to keep
their eggs in every single time that he
says it's a witch hunt it's awful it's
crooked right they have to double down
on that attack this is a manageable
attack for Republicans this is a the
whole Russia thing could keep it in the
news this is great this is an attack
that Republicans can manage there might
be some other lines that they could try
to hit I don't know things are going so
well it's actually really hard for them
to pull something up but at least this
one they can keep a hold on so keep it
in the news - I know this doesn't occur
to anybody but maybe president Trump
actually knows what he's doing maybe the
Republicans know what they're doing and
maybe Democrats are so they're so revved
up that they're being consumed by their
own logic they're being consumed by the
logical conclusions of their own actions
it is the Vengeance of the Lord they rev
it up so much they dish it and they dish
it and they dish it and now I don't know
what it is about the president but
because of him they have to take it -
and there they're forced and they're
wedged into this corner how can they
pivot off of this issue it's not like
Democrats don't read the polls they read
the polls they see oh gosh Americans
don't care about this at all we're
expending all of our energy all of our
capital on this and we're looking like
fools every step of the way we're
getting proven more partisan more
corrupt more crooked but how do they
pivot out of it they've made such a big
deal they've said basically Trump is you
know boris and Natasha from rocky and
bullwinkle they've really invested in
this they can't pivot out of it it's a
great place to put them the Republicans
right now have Democrats against the
ropes everywhere as a matter of culture
as a matter of economics as a matter of
public policy as a matter of electoral
politics they've just got them on the
ropes and I'll say this too I'll close
it on this free speech thing the
vengeance of the Lord with with James
Gunn do I want to live in a world where
people can make jokes ten years ago and
they don't have their lives ruined for
it yes I do it's some conservatives or I
think are being a little obtuse on this
they're saying well look it's not a
First Amendment issue look the market
has spoken
the market has spoken he made these
comments Disney had to fire him it's the
market right but this is looking at free
speech ideologically to narrow free
speech is not just
about politics it's not just about the
First Amendment it's not just about
economics it's not just about the market
it's about the culture what kind of
culture do we want to live in a culture
where you can joke around or a culture
where you can't joke around we obviously
we want to live in a culture where you
can joke around but the left has to has
to stop poisoning that culture and
they're empty until they stop poisoning
that the Vengeance of the Lord will will
keep smacking them in the face and it's
pretty funny to watch it's pretty
enjoyable come back tomorrow
ran a little late as usual I'll come
back tomorrow we've got a lot more to
talk about some great guests this week
and in the meantime I'll see you then
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show the Michael Nolan is produced
by seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy Borg senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you